heart surgeon took his car to his local  garage for a regular service where he  usually exchanged the friendly banter  with the owner a skilled mechanic so  tell me says the mechanic I've been  wondering about what we both do for a  living and how much more you get paid  than me yes as the surgeon well look at  this says the mechanic as he worked on a  big complicated engine I check how it's  running open it up fix the valves put it  all back together so it works good as  new we basically do the same job but  don't we and yet you get paid way more  than me how do you explain that the  surgeon thought for a moment smiled and  replied tried with the engine running